this capture we'll see how in a
hlm have made the inference of
the most plausible explanation
so we've seen so far how
make a reference filtering type ten
wise make the prediction
the last title of inference we want
explore here is the most
plausible ie find out what
is the complete sequence of hidden states
which explains the best
the observation sequence so ds is
until you grow up so we have a
case maximization rather than a sum
we had to do in the others
probability titles in fact one
calls for a very direct link between
others the calculation of the alpha chart that
involved men and the calculation that
will do that the most explanation
plausible that will involve earlier
maximizing then the problem again
once is that if we make the time
to solve the problem of maximization
naively we will still have a
exponential enumeration of the number of
possible sequences that one must consider
to make the maximization so for
to be precise if we take an example of
tea is equal to 3 so we assume that the
just three observations then
the most plausible explanation
found
the dh star sequence from the dh sequence
that I'm going to call h stars that
maximizes the probability of s1 up
is king and h1 until h3 so in fact
here all that we have there all this
line there here actually it corresponds to p2
s1 up is king and p2h 1 that
I call stars until h3 so in
did I just use the years
by the conditional ars to write
this probability joy and com and at the
probity of h1 times the probability of the
sister sacha h1 for the probity of h2
knowing h1 and so on until the
paralysis of s3 sasha
h3 so that's just the independences
conditional that we have there by the
structure to let go even and one has to
make a maximization of finding the
value of cash statements and 2 h 15 until
3 that maximizes this probability is
so except in the case where there are three
it may not be a lot of
sequences but for a great value of
your other than three it's going to make a
exponential number of sequences
grown exponentially compared to
the length of the sequence
however we notice if we do
maxima are on all sequences
it's like making party so this
successful notation is like having the mac
/ h swiss max on age 2 that of the mac
/ h3 and in fact we can put them in
any order of the reports and in
do what we notice is that since
all these unpeeled terms the
products are limited in one order
any one could all push the
terms that depend only 2h hours
here push them to the right and take the
maximize ation only on agen is
she too pushed her to the right one can
do that because if we maximize by
report to achraf but all the terms
who before do not depend on h1 and so
I can pass them in front of the
maximization so if I have only the
ladies who depend on h and end
the ofs that expression here here it's
possible for me from there to maximize for
all possible values ​​2h 2h 2 who
is not specified yet so I could
solve this maximization the support puts
the intermediate calculation in memory then
then to resolve each other
maximization versus hd and again
once I did the same thing I
put all the terms that depend
only from h2 and I put them to
right the maximization and there now
so from my intermediate calculus
here then new calculations here I
to be able to solve any maximization but
now compared to Thursday
I could go on like this until
go to h 3 then finally finished the
maximization when I just described
in words actually it's going to be the equivalent
of the dynamic program that we will use
to solve this problem there and with gonna
to be very very similar to the program
having dinner
dynamic associated with the women market
it's just conferring a maximization
rather than a sum so let's look at them
details i'm going to define alpha
stars as being the probability of s1
until August and is one of the indices of
my chart and h1 up to buy less
one that takes the optimum value up
now and buy and equal a
given value which is the other index of
my chart so notice that it's
very similar to alpha alpha ink
dalphond did we did not have this
part here here we only had that
so can the difference here is
that with alpha normally we have
marginalized the other h while in
our camp the waters maximize for 9
set the value of the best purchases
value find until now and
as in dynamic programming
we will make the link between what has been
calculated at time t
and what was calculated at the moment
before
so we will note a recursion we will
which must be calculated at the moment
follow a convoy bound with what has been
calculated at the moment preceding so by
alpha and toualy definition of the most a
that's equal to that term here so the
probability of what is observed from 1
to healthier ones
so we have a plan instead of first tnt
+ 1 and the maximum sequence of 1
up to healthy witnesses as well as buy
which is equal to gmail here we maximize by
report to me so there we try to so
the equivalent describe a tea is equal to
h stars from 1 until time it's the
same thing as saying I'm going to you
learn what was optimal 1
until witnesses hours i'm going to look
a priority to buy galas a
value of giving j but i'm going to take
the one that is maximum so that's okay
maybe in fact the value lies that goes
maximize that's going to be my h stars of
tea in celebration so this probability so
these two terminals here it corresponds to
h
and you are laurent until you and we have
then bought + 1 supposed to be
equal to 10 10 being Monday what I have
here so as for the calculation of the table
alphabet game can decompose seven
producers like and at the parity attached
from what is observed in one up
your times forgiveness and h1n1 until witness
one that takes its optimum value and https
gala j times the policy bought + 1
skip gallery since ht be
equal acts so we get out we have no
dependence here on observations
previous because of independence
conditional we had previously
in a hlm as well as buy more one
is equal to 1 of which quoted above
is equal to small is is more a being
given that bought + 1 equal to there is still
once it's independent of others
elements in my probity so two
bought then from s to st because of
because it does not have six blocks so we
conditional independence
so here and then whose hair
maximization arises from this expression
here I notice that this term does not
does not depend on gidon I can place
in front of the maximum I notice this term
there here in fact by definition it's
alpha stars jt and I still have more than
this term there he learns quickly and from
make a transition from j to y
in the kachin state so I managed to
to link my story
at & t +1 an actor canvas market
and finally with regard to
initial values ​​of the first column
from my alpha star chart so I
young initialises pde sang gala yx
p of the astreinte equal to small to what
is observed at the first instant knowing
that a welsh tea has so it's a
application of this definition there so
for all gala 1 in fact I have
ask me about thieves 2 h until
1 - 1 until 0 so no dh finally
so that's why I do not have any
maximization for the special coc for you
guys there finally in regards to
find the probability of the sequence
observe and the best sequence
for the hidden state just take the
maximum on the last column of alpha
stars and there now if I want
find find out what is the share of
all this sequence there is what loose
star 1 up big t but what I
will do if I'm going to take up arms
axes of the last column t more
of that I'm going back to borrow the
weapons axes that were made for all
the sequences of the right for all
years from the right to the
left doing what I call to
from the arts max previous so that
it is a concept that is illustrated a little
better with an example and we will do that
in the next hours positive then
we come to our example where I have 4 bits
that have been transmitted and there I want
know what is the sequence of beats
h1 h2 h3 hy4 that the person wanted
really send me so is what has
had noise then that in fact there is
some of the shops are not the ones
beats that had actually been sent
by the person who sent me the
message
so I have my star alpha chart that
genissary reads according to conditions
initialization which is the formula here
we saw previously
so alpha stars 0 1 it's ph is equal
at zero x pds inde equal to zero knowing
that h is equal to zero is 0.9 0.5 so
0.45 that I insert here I do the same
thing with alphand star 1 1mg floor
ready to apply my recursion to the
left to the right
so here we have the formula we saw
previously on the link indicated to
left
the left column with the column of
right so actually the calculation of a
element here is going to involve calculations of
all the elements in the column of
left but instead of having a sum
as was the case with alfa have
a max instead for the alpha body
0.2 stars it will match p2 s2
equal to zero that each age debt equal to
zero times the max between so be alpha
and 3.01 times bought Wales forgiveness hd is
equal to zero bag bought yann at zero or
your censor or half way canvas 1.1
times the policy h2 is equal to zero
shat that h1 and thus matching the choice in
is actually seeing is this
more likely that I have passed 2
0 that I got back to zero or that
I was right and more likely than
I was at 1 to 20 since now I
am at 0 cashed the two things that
are compared here in fact if we do some
calculations in that if the maximum is
the first theme
so in fact what am I going to do in
if I had to program his section to have
a pointer that will bring me back I
got here I did the math of
this element there from the alpha stars
here and if it's pointing to where I want
follow at the end to do the decoding
of the entire sequence corresponds to the
sequence to the most explanation
plausible
so I did the same calculation for
alpha stars 1 2 because if still
once it's the term that depends on
alpha stars
your breasts that fits the max so
it's more likely according to our
calculations to be first was a gala tea
0 then to be switched to h 2 equals 1
than to have been bought gala 1 then
to have gone hot is equal to 1 so
I'll note that with a pointer here
and then I will write in my table
the calculated value and I continue as
that an inhabitant regulating the
left to the right and I fill everything
my table like that by filling but
point also so remembered me
doubs was calculated the different
elements of the painting alphand antoine
then to do the decoding
now I'm looking at the last
column and I take the max so on this
element here here this is the element with
probity or the maximum value in the
column which my last column and so
that's the probability of the
best sequence
now i want to know so this is
well I have this reality right now I
want to know what is the sequence with
this probability the sequence of toques
hidden that generated this priority
maximum
and when I'm going to do what I'm going
follow the arrows in this case also said
if I go there water I go
here and from here I surrender the skin when
I spend here
so if I read all this stuff
that I'm going to do and it's that h4 is
equal to 1 in the best sequence h3t
gallas 0 in the best h2 sequence
equal to 1 in the best sequence then
agent is zero in the sequence
with the highest probability
notice that the pointers are
important it would not have worked
just take the max on each of
columns will have to follow the pointers if
I had done the max on each of
columns I would have rather selected six
6 to 10 h from tig to 0 it was not the
good answer so for this problem if
although I have observed 000 1
in fact what is most likely
is that the person who sent me a
message wanted to send me to sing gas
is equal to 1 h web equal to zero hk
rigal so it's more likely that
wanted to send me 01 01
but that because of the noise in the
transmission that my second goal was
britt and then that I got instead
of the brain
that's how we calculate
the most plausible explanation in a
hlm